france has historically not been shy
about territorial expansion be it in the
days of napoleon when it grew to this or
overseas where france built a large
colonial empire and french leadership
were by and large used to getting most
of the territorial demands that they
made of their defeated foes with a very
notable exception the sarland here which
despite a lot of effort from france
evaded their attempts to annex it but
how come why wasn't france ever able to
annex the sarland permanently so to
begin the sarland was briefly a part of
france during napoleon napoleon's years
of frolicking across europe but at that
point the lands held no special value
and they were simply the land west of
the rhine that napoleon wanted to make a
more defensible frontier after he was
dealt with france's borders returned to
this and later in that same century an
important discovery was made in the
sarland coal which was not only
important for heating and power but also
was fundamental in the production of
steel which was needed to produce
weapons in the late 19th century these
needs left france in a bind france had
very little coal of its own within its
own borders or even across its empire
and as such it needed to import it and
it did this from germany who could
switch off that supply at any moment and
thus for france to be secure it needed
its own large source of coal and its
leaders rying up the sarlan to be that
source as you'll know world war one saw
france and germany come to blows and
after germany's defeat the french wanted
the tsar land for their own the problem
was that simply grabbing your neighbor's
lands and making them your own was now
frowned upon by britain and the united
states who are pushing for things like
self-determination in europe that is not
the rest of the world nobody asked them
since the sarland was populated by
germans the french opted not to grab it
for their own but to do something a bit
more subtle and clever it was broken off
of germany and made into a league of
nations mandate for 15 years and at the
end of such time there would be a
referendum to decide on whether it would
return to germany stay independent or
join france and the french thought that
given germany's issues it was likely
that the people of starland would
overwhelmingly vote to join france but
fun fact no this may surprise you but
there was a second world war which
germany sticking with tradition lost as
well and the french still in need of
that sweet sweet coal figured that
they'd give grabbing the sarland one
more go when germany was divided into
occupation zones the french broke the
sarland off of germany again but this
time it was made a french protectorate
this annoyed britain and america but
france didn't care because they kept
getting invaded by germany so as far as
they were concerned this was fair
compensation by 1949 the sarland was
deeply linked with the french economy
and the living standards that the people
there had already recovered well ahead
of the rest of europe and it was clear
to everybody concerned that the sarland
was well on its way to becoming a part
of france proper so what stopped this it
was the unification of the allied
occupation zones into west germany the
cold war meant that the west needed
germany on their side and that germany
wanted the sarland back whereas france
wanted security and so its leaders
pushed for the creation of the european
coal and steel community which would
make whoever owned the sarland
irrelevant since france would be
guaranteed access to its coal by which
point the french were much less
interested in having the sarland for
themselves and were pushing for a
unified european approach to policy
something which required germany on side
that said the french gave the people of
the sarland a vote in 1955 on remaining
independent which the majority said no
to and two years after this the sarland
was reincorporated into germany where it
remains today i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker mr wolf sky
chappelle jerry lamdin yn hockey marvin
cassell jordan longley gareth turner rod
d martin bugley wiggly captain cydog
spencer lightfoot corso wolfe gustav
swan matthew shipley winston caywood
robert wetzel aaron the white marcus
asner maggie paxkowski anthony beckett
alex schwinn mo the mukwopa coppertone
spinning three plates ben evanson
charles the first adam stalter and
scottish trekkie